all right
you see how far he's gonna go all right
so what i see is
his hand is sometimes here that's not
very much
okay and sometimes his hand is way over
here
now if he moves out of the way please
this is not the inverse bar
so the question was what after i do
the initial angle cancellation on the
cross
lateral shoulder what am i doing with
his arm
some of you are
opening it up you see
then feel feel that
and you feel that which one gives you
back your slack
this this one does you see his watch all
the play in his shoulder
is all that okay
so feel how it went dead
okay so let's say you uh try to turn in
him
do you see the arm's doing that
let's say you try to pull my arm
you see let's say you try to extend my
arm
let's say you try to curl my arm
but my arm is in that space
and with it you're
between these two points you're
affecting this mass
between the two points between the two
points
[Music]
so just like when i'm here that's what
moves him
and now i have two points two points are
moving his mouth
this is different different
you have two points of contact two
points of contact
two points of contact working together
two points
take out the slack in his arm
by taking out the slack in your arm and
using it
as two points of control okay
not two unique points
or one than the other point two points
of control
two points so i'll show you my
preference because
i'm not doing that to get his head down
the two points are moving him oh
so i just leave my hand there you see i
i want my hand here
as opposed to down here because i wasn't
using it to cut him
so my hands up here so uh i can strike
from here
okay so then he comes up take his
balance
and then it goes here that's when i open
the handle
play with that see what you think
here's my two points of control he's
going to go
this is where i can distract
[Music]
then open
oh
um so let's go let's go back to the
first part of the test about
okay so look how much
he moves okay
i find that important that because
that's going to train your
your ik adhesions it's going to train
your ide
but leaving them there
[Music]
uh i don't think that translates into
any kind of gui so
uh in other words he's he's
doing his stuff you're never gonna get
faster
you're never gonna get back there
the way you tend to get edemi when it's
more freestyle
is he's going i take that pattern right
he's gonna turn to adjust i keep turning
this is kind of where you get your edema
okay
it's more a combination of either him
going by me all the way
or a combination of me going and him
going so
we're here he's he starts to take that
turn and i move this way
i'm a human but the idea of
getting to the back
doesn't work okay so
might as well do the do the ik adhesion
so
you're moving him from one control point
and then you're going to like one
control point
back to two control points
so you you're not gonna go around so you
can just
right and you're gonna move them
[Music]
there you see this badly he doesn't even
want to go that far
he's got to go
here move
kind of lobster boom there we go
okay make everyone move through your ik
adhesion
and create the opening to the rim
so wall that's the opening there
that is not an opening he's standing in
between
so warm this way
okay